version on Family Guy was Kermit the
Frog doing doing taking I'm not gonna be
able member the speech I don't have any
money on a very specific set of skills
nightmare for somebody like you if you
don't let the girl go
I will track you down all right we'll
find you we'll kill you
[Applause]
it's all the ligaments that hole your
shoulder down snap so my collarbone kind
of sits up now don't have full function
of my shoulder does it hurt no it's
awesome
what dying should I do
I don't know I feel the need the need
for speed about ten years ago I did a
film with Morgan Freeman it was a really
small film and the first 10 pages or 10
minutes of the film are us to just
driving together in a car and talking
and it took three days to shoot and he
didn't talk to me the entire times like
in between takes right because he had so
much dialogue I learned later right okay
so he was just you know so in between we
wouldn't really chat and Boo you're in
the car together for three days and then
the end of the third day he just turns
to me and he goes Jonah Jonah Bobo no
banana fanna fo fona
me Mom momona Jonah comfortable
weird moments of my life and I just
didn't know what to say so I just said
thank you he said it was quiet again
then he said do me do your name and he's
like yeah do my name and I was like
Morgan Morgan Morgan me my mom Morgan
Morgan all right and then we never spoke
again is very large so the people who
aren't did it must be very pissed off
what do you mean and in a family right
in the show
aren't you the show [ __ ] them he's very
strongly that all woman should maintain
some pubic hair Katherine feels very
strongly about this
that would be retaining to be allotment
an aspect of husbandry about attraction
you mean would be to maintain take it
out every now and then comb it like a
power outage lights out like a power
[Applause]
[Music]
I could kill the mist every time we kiss
just didn't know it down for like this
desert there's a flash-forward warning
will it will rain in the morning and
there be portals we had to go down this
hallway and I had to run I was meant to
be naked and and it was very dark and
and I jokingly went in and I said I want
a closed set for this and the first idea
was laughing anyway went to the first
take and I'm running there's a very
intense scene where I first realize have
an adamantium skeleton I've been
experimenting I'm naked there's blood
I'm like and as I run around the corner
the first ad had the entire crew
characters are in scenes together yeah
do you do one line after the other do
you all do all one and then go back do
the other one when I do a table read
yeah I have to jump back and forth hey
how much going on hello that man doing
her way
[Laughter]
against the books bookshelf as you do
and it's with the lovely James McAvoy
he's a friend he's really lovely and
it's always awkward because he's brand
and that's awkward and we're in the
middle of it and suddenly this voice
just goes
Kirra wank him off seem like you are a
fan of the older lady girl the
weatherman said it's cloudy skies right
there between your thighs
I want it soaking wet all over the beds
do you sing lyrics he broke them
[Applause]
hey it sounds looks better when you sing
okay where should I beat you with a
cushion
just just way back yeah exactly like
that I spent a lot of my life looking
like a dick up
what are you telling me you've never met
I used to see something have you never
satisfy you gonna do something really
have you never met a spice girl I'm wait
hold on
have you never met a spice girl riding
the flash okay now as you know
[Music]
it's very rare it's very rare for more
than one Spice Girl to appear together
[Applause]
[Music]
so they're not here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]